حياكم الله نعم سفيان في الساعه الاخيره
نود الاشاره الى الاوضاع الميدانيه
بالتحديد في خانيونس جنوبيه قطاع غزه حيث
عاوت المدفعيه الاسرائيليه استئناف القصف
على احياء حي الامل والمخيم الغربي وتسمع
اصوات انفجارات كبيره تهز هذه المناطق
بفعل اطلاق القذائف وكذلك تسمع اصوات
اشتباكات في هذه الساعه في هذه المنطقه
التي تشهد تواجد عدد كبير من الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه التي تحاول الدخول
الى قلب مخيم خان يونس كذلك قلب منطقه حي
الامل الذي يقع بداخله ايضا مشفى الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني المحاصر منذ سبعه ايام
وهو في مرمى نران القوات الاسرائيليه التي
تعيق ايضا عمل هذه الطواقم التي استخدمت
بديلا لهذا المشفى مشفا ميدانيا على شاطئ
البحر الغربي خانيونس ونقلت بعضا من
مركبات الاسعاف للعمل على اجلاء المصابين
وانتشال الشهداء خاصه من المنطقه الغربيه
بمعنى ان مشفى الامل ومجمع ناصر الطبي
توقفت الخدمات الصحيه بشكل كامل منذ بد
العمليه البريه على المنطقه الغربيه حيث
ان الاليات العسكريه تحاصر هذين المشفي من
جميع الاتجاهات وهما في مرمى نيران القوات
الاسرائيليه التي تطلق النار والقذائف
المدفعيه التي ادت لتعطل خدمات هذين
المفين الذين ايضا يضمان اعدادا كبيره من
النازحين الذين ما زالوا يحتمون داخل هذين
المشفي وهناك خشيه حقيقيا بان السيناريو
المشفى الاندونيسي وكمان العدوان وكذلك
ايضا مجمع الشفاء ان يعاد بذات الوثيره
وذات المشاهد القاسيه بحق هذا المجمع في
ظل تاكيد وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه في قطاع
غزه بان ساحات المجمع قد تحولت الى مقبره
جماعيه لنحو 150 شهيدا عدا 30 كما استبت
سفيان مجهولي الهويه فضلا عن ذلك تعطل
بعضا من الخدمات الصحيه وايضا القذائف ادت
الى اعطال اصابه خزانات المياه العلويه
التي تسببت في انقطاع المياه عن مجمع ناصر
الطبي واجزاء كبيره منه وبالتالي هناك خطر
حقيقي على المرضى والجرحى داخل المجمع
وكذلك ايضا نفاذ بعضا من المستلزمات
الطبيه خاصه التي تتعلق في التخدير وغرف
العنايه المركزه الى جانب الوقود الذي بدا
في العد التنازلي وقد شارف على الانتهاء
وربما نحن امام اربعه ايام بحص وزاره
الصحه الفلسطينيه وقد يتوقف مجمع ناصر
الطبي تماما عن العمل وهذا
يعني حكم بالاعدام البطيء لهؤلاء المرضى
والجرحى الذين امتلاوا في او يتواجدون في
داخل مجمع عناصر الطبي غربي خان يونس كذلك
مشفى الامن الذي يعمل بطاقته ال المحدوده
جدا وقد تعامل مساء امس مع شهيد واربعه من
المصابين هم من النازحين في داخل ساحاتها
هذا المشفى بعدما تعرضوا لاطلاق نار من
قبل ميارات اسرائيليه هناك ايضا غارات
جويه كانت مساء الخميس في الساعات
المتاخره طالت احياء جوره العقاد والكتيبه
ومنطقه العريشيه ومنطقه ايضا وسط خان يونس
ودوه انفجارات كبيره العمليات تتركز في
هذه الساعه في مخيم خانيونس وحي الامل
والحي الهولندي ومنطقه بطن السميم ومنطقه
وسط خانيونس قبل قليل كان هناك اطلاق
قنابر اناره من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه في
المنطقه الشرقيه لخان يونس كذلك المنطقه
الوسطى وهذا مؤشر ربما على تحرك بعض
الاليات العسكريه في هذه المناطق عاده
عندما تطلق تلك القذائف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه تشير بشكل واضح الى وجود
تحركات عسكريه على الارض للقوات
الاسرائيليه كذلك ايضا كان هناك اطلاق
قنابل اناره من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه في
المنطقه الجنوبيه من مدينه غزه وهذا ايضا
مؤشر ربما على تحرك لبعض الاليات العسكريه
في هذا المحور الجنوبي الغربي الذي شهد
غاره على الاقل في ساعات متاخره من مساء
الخميس في منطقه تل الهواء بالقرب من دوار
الخور تحديدا وكذلك ايضا اطلاق نابل
الاناره شمالي المنطقه الوسطى في منطقه
الغراق وشمالي النصيرات وهذا يشير ربما
ايضا الى تحرق اليات عسكريه اسرائيليه في
هذه المنطقه التي كانت قد شهدت منذ بدء
الحرب على قطاع غزه قصفا مكثفا وكذلك
عمليه بريه استمرت عده اسابيع ادت الى
تدمير كامل للمنازل في منطقه المغرا وجحر
الديك و كذلك الزهراء وشمالي ان سيارات
شماليه المنطقه الوسطى من قطاع غزه في
المنطقه الشماليه من القطاع هناك قصف
متقطع من قبل المدفعيه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه التي تطلق بعضها من قضائها
على احياء بلده بيت لاهيا وجباليا وتسمع
اصوات اشتباكات متقطعه في المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه من هذه البلده المضمره
تماما وكانت قد شهرت انسحابا تكتيكيا
للاليات العسكريه الاستراليه في الاسابيع
المنصرمه لكن تعود بين الحين والاخر هذه
الاليات التوغل في في هذه المنطقه وتشهد
تصديا كبيرا من قبل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
في المناطق المدمره حيث تخرج المقاومون
اللي التصدي الى هذه الاليات كذلك شاهدنا
اطلاقا للمقدسات الصاروخيه من منطقه
شماليه قطاع غزه صوب بلدات الغلاف الشمالي
الشمالي المتاخمه لحدود شمالي قطع غزه
وسرايا القدس تبنت هذا الاطلاق للصواريخ
لليوم ربما ض على التوالي يتم اطلاق
مقدسات صاروخيه من منطقه شمالي قطاع غزه
هذه الصوره الاجماليه فيما يتعلق بتطورات
خاصه في الساعات الاخيره في المنطقه
الجنوبيه كذلك المنطقه الوسطى والشماليه
من قطاع غزه هاني الشاعر مرسل الجزيره من
رفح شكرا جزيلا لك